what we have with big Pharma and these
medical practices political protection
far left extremists saying do not look
into it and the media saying that's
right if you do something's wrong with
you yep remember when the New York Times
wrote not to think critically
I gotta tell you man if you I look if if
I don't know I don't know how to help
these people genuinely if they're like I
was told not to think critically so I
stopped so listen I mean since we were
like five years old right Nursery School
kindergarten you're told I mean it was
it was like the most ubiquitous
statement on the planet when you came to
doctors get a second opinion yeah until
we learn fauci's name then anyway if you
got a second opinion you were a crazy
conspiracy theorist you were
anti-science you didn't trust the
experts give me a break